first of all in the short run the most
important thing we can do is to lift the
bottom the working bottom by raising the
minimum wage we had a big argument about
this yesterday you may have seen there's
a lot of people who argue that every
time you raise the minimum wage you cut
off opportunities for young people and
jobs and everything I've been doing this
a long time I it never happened any time
I was involved in it and you could raise
the minimum wage so much for example
it's gonna be interesting to see how the
Seattle external wounds you know we were
talking about that with secretary proven
to be very interesting to see but the
research indicates that if you kind of
keep the minimum wage at roughly half
the median you can get the best of both
worlds and you can give people enough
money to live on and that adds to
economic growth because people they
don't have a money to say so they
circulated in the economy it turns over
and it contributes to growth so I think
that is important I think making some
adjustments in the earned income tax
credit and the child care tax credit to
help working people with families at the
lower end of the wage scale is important
the Earned Income Tax Credit when I was
president alone lifted more than 3
million people out of poverty and more
than 2 million children and enabled us
to have the only period since the late
70s when the bottom twenty percent of
earners actually increased their
earnings by more than the top 20% did as
much as the top 5% that's pretty
impressive the we can do that and I
think it's important the third thing
that will help a lot is it's going to
take us through three years looks like
but we got to get all the states to take
this Medicaid exemption expansion it's a
lay down it creates thousands of jobs in
every state brings money in
and rewards working people the people
who have opposed Medicaid expansion
Virginia just had a study that said
their budget would actually generate a
billion dollars plus more revenues over
the next 10 years if they take it and
pay the ten percent match after three
years then if they say the match and
don't expect because of all the jobs
that will be created in all the savings
and increased health care you've got to
give working families a chance to take
care of their kids so she lifts the
bottom that's important now over the
long run the social mobility maybe even
more important that is we approved in
America that we would accept slightly
even under the best of conditions
slightly higher rate of economic
inequality than many of the most wealthy
countries in Europe in return for more
social mobility that is we would take in
more immigrants and give them a chance
to start out low on the totem pole and
work like crazy and bill middle-class
lives but that's not a credible position
for us to have anymore because we have
less social mobility in America than a
lot of other countries now the candidate
seems to have even a higher median
income then we do that is it the 50th
percentile it appears that this year for
the first time since World War two
Canada's income is higher than ours and
there are several countries with higher
incomes in the lower forty percent of
the workplace so I just think so should
we borrow some of their policies yes